d-backs and the reds and the home opener
for 20-21
and their ram truck starting pitcher
taylor widener 26-year-old right-hander
a winner in his first major league start
sunday at san diego first pitch jesse
winker deep shot right center welcome
back waker
first pitch swinging
the machine travels
[Applause]
right there he dropped the change up and
rings up suarez taylor widener
strands that lead off double
right-hander tyler malley your ram truck
starter for the reds nine strikeouts in
five innings he beat the cardinals in
his debut last saturday runners go again
lifted shallow left winker
sliding grab
he worked on his speed in the off season
and that might have aided him
alley whispers to himself i got it i got
it the second great play of the day for
the lead-off man
that's a well-hit ball by barnhart deep
in the gap it's gonna get down to get to
the wall
oh the reds have had two base runners a
pair of lead off doubles like their
chances of getting barnhart in from
third with only one out oh here's jesse
winker kelly down and away target 3-1
smoked
left field base hit barnhart scores and
the reds lead one nothing
well this kid can hit i mean you talk
about getting the barrel the bat to the
baseball
[Applause]
some good change-ups there for taylor
widener after he
got behind in the count a little bit
tyler naquin do up
and naquin puts a charge into one deep
right field way way back and gone
he's done it again
three games in a row a home run for
tyler naquin five on the year two
nothing reds
see if he goes down there again
that's where the target is from barnhart
swinging a miss how you called it
the soothsayer chris welsh he
prophesizes and o'malley delivers
man on one out
2-2
there's another rip by winker his third
hit of the game
stop at second blandino and jesse winker
hasn't played in nearly a week and he's
three for three
that pitch in is on the ground past the
dive of rojas over to third blandino
up to second winker base is loaded
joey votto bases loaded 349 four
grannies
shift on with the bases loaded 3-0
ground ball right side missed on the
backhand muffed by escobar everyone's
safe blandino scores three nothing reds
played after the swing almost falling
over
he's choked up now the pitch swing gonna
miss he flails it one away and down on
strikes le castro he strikes out for the
second time tonight that's seven
strikeouts by red's pitching
oh two
swinging miss
that had some drop on it
tj antone straight filthy back-to-back
case for nothing tucker barnhart bats
that is well hit that's a fair ball
naquin scores
barnhart's got a couple of knocks
and he's got a couple of doubles as he
slides in
and the reds expand the lead five
nothing
suarez gives a ride
that's going to
get down all the way to the wall
suarez
chugs up to second a double for a eu
haneo suarez and demanded scoring
position with one down
escobar drives one to right and that's
going to get down in the corner it's off
the wall castellanos plays the high hop
and eduardo who homered yesterday in
denver
doubles tonight in phoenix that's how
you get things started drives it to
center
senzel backing up still backing up to
the track this will get escobar home
and the d-backs are on the board make it
5-1 the rbi for carson kelly
sends this one out toward castigato's
who plays it on a hop there's a base hit
for pavon
base it for the castro it's in the gap
haven smith big turn at second sunzelle
picks it up pretty quickly out there
and the diamondbacks have something
going with his seventh inning here
calhoun locks his one to right field
castellanos won't get there it's off the
wall
pavon scores here comes loco
cole calhoun is back in town
5-3 ball game
three runs in the seventh nine run comes
to the plate escobar who lashes them up
double
who hits one high in the air deep right
field castellanos at the wall we're tied
they were down five nothing it's now
five five eduardo escobar
homers for the second consecutive ball
game now the upper up to tucker barnhart
if the reds are to score
here in the tent
well left center field base hit suarez
scores
and tucker barnhart delivers again his
third knock his second rib of the night
reds back on top six to five
[Applause]
chop to third short hop cabrera they go
to short way for the force on barnhart
but the reds get a run diamondbacks
coming up
flanked off the glove
and everybody moves up now a base hit
can win the ball game the little things
barnhart was looking for something else
back to back two out walks the last
intentional
ground ball
farmer
and the cincinnati reds have won six
straight
they are six and one for the first time
since 1994.
as a.g rocks the cradle and the reds win
it in ten six to five well that was an
exciting ball game i mean it looked like
the reds are going to run away with this
thing from the very beginning they end
up having to win it in overtime
and uh good for amir garrett coming in
here and throwing the ball well
uh had a little drama there
but man oh man you come away with a w